donald trump's real estate portfolio
took a beating during the pandemic but
his holdings in palm beach florida have
had quite the boost forbes estimates
trump's real estate in the scenic island
town has jumped 155 million dollars in
value during lockdown many of america's
wealthiest people flocked to south
florida for relief this was good
business for trump who is one of the
most significant landowners in palm
beach his best known property of course
being mar-a-lago the club produces more
than 20 million dollars of revenue a
year
before the pandemic forbes estimated it
was worth 170 million dollars now based
on our calculations and discussions with
real estate experts we believe it is
worth 300 million dollars
this would make mar-a-lago one of the
most expensive homes in america
trump also owns two other houses and an
empty lot beside one of them which are
next to the club
they're worth about 28 million dollars
up 10 million since the start of the
pandemic trump is only known to have
bought one piece of real estate while he
was in office as president
this was another mansion across the
street from mar-a-lago which his sister
sold to him for about 19 million dollars
in 2018. in today's palm beach market
that looks like a bargain as the house
is estimated to be worth about 35
million dollars today
you